so hi hello you may notice that there is
about 105 kilos of missing Aryan
perfection of the farside just there and
if you're just listening you will notice
that there is not the sound of a massive
art trivial squeaking all over the lemon
it yes Ophir
that is because johnny is away on
holiday so it's just me and Yousef today
and we are going to be talking about how
to get lean for your summer holidays
this is actually take - this is
technically take - we had a technical
problem but this salmon it's in a pure
gold pure how to get ready for summer
gold so if this is if this is not as
good then it's not our fault we already
gave up our best so I hope you get lean
few summer holidays I did a little
Instagram post about this yesterday and
had an awful lot of messages coming back
not least of all because it's due and a
lot of people will have realized [ __ ]
I'm going away on holiday within the
next eight weeks and maybe not as lean
or as muscular as I want to be and you
have to turn the top off on the beach or
I'm gonna wear a bikini or whatever it
might be the point that I think struck a
chord with a lot of people was what I
said about the typical approach for
getting lean for holidays and if you
have a look online a lot of the
resources that you will find about how
to get lean will focus on potentially
fitness competitions or long-term slow
deficit fat loss approaches the crucial
difference between stepping on stage and
going on holiday too would be throw
Marbella is that when you step on stage
all that you're going to do is flex and
tense when you go out tim-mah mayor or
abathur you're gonna be drinking corona
and having baguette all day every day
forget forget as in one baguette one
huge [ __ ] off baguette yeah you take a
bit out you know taking a book out with
you another
s10 long we get I think this is where
the the alcohol reference goes oh is
there some kind of drink called baguette
no no you do you mean baguette baguette
yeah just as I get liver get yeah so is
it llobregat don't know I'm not sure
it's it's something you're gonna have a
lot carts and what happens is people
will drill their die into the ground
reduce drop carbs out completely
everyone's got that ex bodybuilder
current bodybuilder friend in the gym yo
mate well what you need to do yeah is
two scoops strawberry yeah so morning
and and then fish and a right kick but
midday and it's just like all that
you're doing is creating an environment
in which your body will absorb Corona
like a [ __ ] sponge and so many times
I went away on a holiday at drill Munson
drove us off into the ground on like a
1,500 calorie per day allowance got out
on a holiday look peeled to bits for one
day the next morning would be even
better because I was dehydrated to hell
and then as soon as I had that first
breakfast in the hotel
I just balloon out there's no shape left
and any size that I did have eight weeks
ago has been lost due to this
catastrophic deficit damn it
so what I wanted to do was try and put
together a little bit of a structure and
some principles that you can take away
if you've got between four and ten weeks
something like that until your holiday
so are we right in saying that if you've
got less than four weeks until you go on
holiday it's gonna be very difficult to
make a profound change
honestly if you've got less than four
weeks don't bother just carry on as
normal just right in a wing in yourself
suffer needlessly like you're not gonna
elicit any change in your body visibly
in four weeks time and I think what you
said is is interesting because it right
now it's the 2nd of June it's a common
question that the Weger in terms of
inquiries I'm sure you've got some
messages about this stuff as well and
it's endemic
of the the mindset that we have towards
fitness which is JIT I've got 28 days
I've got to drastically undo the last 35
years of my bad cemetary habits and make
a change in my body from now and it's
like what's the rush
like people often you know that there's
no there's no thought given to it until
suddenly up at my flight [ __ ] I need to
make a change yeah and you know 2nd of
June it's cutting it fine to be honest
I'm not I'm gonna I'm not gonna
sugarcoat that as you said four to ten
weeks so if you have say eight weeks so
if you're going around a holiday after
sort of the start of July start to make
July up until the end of the summer
you're sweet well yeah you're not sweet
but you are salvageable you're
definitely some salvageable by that
point and I think there's a lot of key
principles here but the first thing is
that muscle game is a very slow process
and so all we can expect at this point
is to lose fat okay and we would saying
this of us on the first take hood my
favorite thing when you're looking at a
Facebook photo of someone's like summer
holiday and it's like six lads all
eating but five of them 18% body fat
one of them's like 6% body fat huge and
just shredded that's like odd one out
there that's the guy who has it as part
of his lifestyle as opposed to a crush
died exactly like that is the result of
all 10 years of the previous training so
there's no point that if you're worried
about how you're gonna look relative to
your swoll mate that you're gonna be
comparable and so don't set that as your
reference point like realize that if you
are and so that the numbers wise eight
weeks away 80 kilo man 18 percent body
fat you diaster just to interject there
am i right in saying that the principles
are the same for men and women yeah I
don't be talking about if in this time
period it's this the same for sure okay
so both both genders can broadly take
the same approach that we apply here
yeah exactly so for women 18% body fat
will actually look quite lean dating
somebody
I mean your yeah you as a woman you
pretty much start to get abs at 15% body
fat so if you're not sure about these
ranges don't get hung up on the
percentage
I use this as coming for anchor point
but don't try and get caliphate or
anything basically if you're carrying a
bit of extra fat and your abs are not
visible
you've got no deltoids triceps
separation you probably around 18
percent body fat and then you know
linearly faster as that goes up so so if
you're a run that let's say 80 kilo man
8 weeks time aggressive diet would mean
1 percent of your body weight lost per
week assuming you hit your average
calories without fail for that time and
we have to hit the ground running
there's no time for [ __ ] around when
you've got eight weeks to go you can't
ease yourself into this program this is
like yeah the time is already well
that's insane that's definitely one of
the things that I think people need to
realize that if you have left it as late
as you've only got eight weeks and to
the one of the things that we need to
state from the beginning is eight weeks
sounds like ages mmm but physiologically
in terms of fat loss eight eight weeks
it's a couple of seconds okay like it's
not a tremendously long amount of times
that you have you have less time than
you think
you can't take liberties now so if
you've got if you're planning to go away
this winter beginning your cut now six
months in advance it's mean it's too
long even six months unless what it
depends on how far you are supposed yeah
okay so they're getting beginning a
fitness regime that works towards that
you've got six months you've got time to
even gain a bit muscle than then and
then come on trainer and then we're even
reverse back up but eight weeks yeah not
long enough
and so one percent of your body weight
per week for eight weeks at 80 kilos
body weighs 800 grams of weight loss per
week 6.4 kilos of weight loss over eight
weeks so that is going to make a visible
difference in how you look an awful lot
yeah it will but that I mean that one
percent of body weight loss per week is
the top end of how much weight you
should be losing each week it's gonna
impact on as you said like how you feel
how the potential rebound at the end so
yeah obviously the faster you lose fat
the higher the cost at the
and so this is something you have to
bear in mind anyway
the principles are the same that we want
to be lifting weights to retain as much
muscle as possible even if you're a
woman
there's something that the most common
and the most heartbreaking Fitness
mistake I see with women and I'm glad
you said all the principles the same for
men at women is that the woman who's
like I want to drop a couple of dress
sizes I'm gonna pound the cardio and eat
just a bit of cabbage every day some
salary and it's like you are only going
to look like a smaller version of
yourself
but just as shapeless and yeah your
dress might be a smaller size but not
actually gonna have any any shape you're
not gonna look any better than 100% and
the other thing as well is that now
especially since Instagram Fitness
chicks and stuff for a lot more
prevalent having a good set of legs as a
woman like it sort of it you know a
shapely set of legs is kind of cool
right like it's not it's not that seen
for CrossFit in CrossFit girls to go out
wearing dresses and stuff like that like
it's it's actually almost desirable
definitely I think probably if you asked
go anyone look more muscular on
Instagram because the you can't tell
scale yeah when you see some of these
CrossFit girls in real life they're
absolutely babes and it's not you know
you see the Wonder folks anything ah
she's a bit big but actually they've got
small frames and yeah they just face
still very very womanly if you put them
in a dress you're done so yeah what
you're saying is that we need to hit the
ground running we don't have any time to
lose that lifting weights
rather than pounding cardio is a good
start so for me out put forward what my
proposal would be for a pre-holiday
routine and why and then I'll let you
could take it and I like or yours
forward so I am the sort of person who
is inherently very lazy and I need to
stack the deck in my favor you may have
noticed you the fact that we do endless
episodes of life hacks that shortcuts to
an effective outcome as something that I
value quite highly for me I need to try
and make all of the right decisions as
easy as possible what that means is I
will get up in the morning I would have
black coffee I would go for a walk on
the morning reason for that is firstly
allows me to clear my head
secondly it allows me to get a little
bit of low intensity steady-state cardio
in now
the list versus high intensity today I'm
not really that bothered about for me
personally I do CrossFit a lot so my
high end power endurance output gets
looked after by my training methodology
should probably clarify that you did
CrossFit not to burn calories you need
CrossFit because you enjoyed CrossFit
yes yeah it's not it's not a voltage
easy on us it's yeah it just happens to
be the methodology that I'm following
but on a morning if you get up and you
go for a walk you've got some fresh air
in you you've had your coffee you're set
for the day so that's a few a few
different big wins just yeah exactly
that you've put in the bag and the low
intensity steady-state stuffs nice get
back
prep your food for the day either pay
someone to meal prepping company there's
loads especially in Newcastle Aurora
kitchen spoon and nutrition there's a
load of different guys that do awesome
food prepping in Newcastle so check them
out or look in your local area if not
prep your food yourself on a morning
get yourself out for the day for me
personally I would train around about
midday or a little bit earlier it means
that my training is done for the day and
I don't have to worry about it
going out the diet and going on to my
calories I would tend to have between
200 and 300 grams of a training day
around about 200 grams on a recovery day
and about 100 grams on a rest day of
what cops okay sorry then let's say Cal
let just say grant there just assume
that everyone knew I was Sophie you
might have said Cubs on my yesterday
over um yeah of cops protein and fat
would generally stay the same a little
bit more fat on my right on my rest days
some of the strategies that I use for
curbing hunger would be natural set
yogurt on a night time which is without
a doubt the single best approach for
stopping yourself from trying to cheat
on your diet firstly if you don't
achieve in your diet do not have junk in
the house if you like me I've got a
sweet tooth and you do not have
chocolate bars in the house you will not
eat them you can't eat what isn't in
your cupboard and going to the shop
getting yourself up at 10 o'clock at
night because you've got craving for a
chocolate I'm walking all the way to the
shop misty built up some steps though
yeah you've got you've got you've got
some other intensity cardio in but it's
just it's probably not gonna like it's
not gonna happen you're gonna protect
yourself so yeah for me I would natural
set yogurt scoop of protein powder some
mixed blueberries and unless you're an
absolute animal that will satiate pretty
much anyone's craving for something
sweet the macros are unbelievable like
it'll fit you can probably add it on top
of any diet I think and it'll in total
it'll be like 120 calories something
like that for a big tub bowl of protein
e fruity niceness and then your sweet
from there so berries are like wizardry
as well like considering how low calorie
density they are from what you get yeah
there's a lot of volume and they taste
pretty good so yes my few little tips
would be get up on a morning if you want
to do the high intensity stuff then go
and do some hill sprints something like
between 10 to 20 rounds with 30 second
rest run up a hill then walk back down
wait for 30 seconds at the bottom and
then go again if you can do that 10
times of a moderately steep hill that it
has output for about 30 seconds
something like that so you gain like 2
to 1 way to rest something like that
sorry
2 to 1 rest to work that's a good way to
get some cardio in in the morning then
if you can train later on in the evening
or the afternoon make sure that you're
lifting weights don't get stuck or hung
up on the
honing from going to super high rack
ranges
still focus on the moneymaker sets which
are between sort of six to fourteen
wraps at a weight which is moderately
heavy and still testing it unlikely that
you've gotten unless you're new to
training that you're going to PR during
this particular period but yeah that's
that would be broadly my approach what
you're thinking so I like that you've
split it out into a day daily schedule
and also the principle of make the good
decisions as easy as possible and make
the bad decisions as hard as possible is
definitely the way to set up your
environment for success because if you
have to consciously make the good
decision and it's you know you have to
jump through a bunch of Hoops each time
yeah then by 5:00 p.m.
you've the decision fatigue sets in
which is a real thing like you you tie
everything runs gonna well yeah miss
training I'll miss training chocolate
bars in the cupboard any of that
definitely the yogurt thing there's
there's some evidence behind this as
well which is interesting
we've done studies looking at if you
feed someone yogurt with a little spoon
and then see how how many calories they
eat subsequently in the rest of the day
it's lower than if they were to eat
other types of food and they there was
an equivalent amount of yeah so they
they compared calorie matched amounts of
tuna carbs crackers milk away all those
kind of things in the wave weigh in
yogurt with a higher sense of satiety
you mean you're gonna feel better from
that on an on a side point on the making
sure that it's easy for you to to
stack the deck in your favor that
includes prepping your food so roll back
the clock from the morning do you need
to prep your food if you've got chicken
in the freezer and you haven't defrosted
it when you wake up the next morning
you can't cook the chicken that's still
frozen so you default to Coco Pops
exactly
you know you think oh well [ __ ] it the
diets gone for today so I'll just
ordering some takeaway or I'll do
whatever I got a great to get a pastry
like you know it is all about making the
good decisions as easy as possible and
the bad decisions as hard as possible
remembering that you are going to have a
lower you're already using up an awful
lot of willpower here dr. Roy Baumeister
is study they did with turnips where he
had two groups of people in a room one
group had cookies and turnips and
another group just had cookies the group
that just had cookies were allowed to
eat them or not if they wanted the group
that had cookies and turnips were told
they couldn't eat the cookies and could
only eat the turnips so they were then
given they were then given a problem of
Lee demanding tasks to do afterwards and
the group that wasn't allowed to eat the
cookies gave up 50% faster than you are
so it's it's a finite resource willpower
and yet it said thus that's such an
interesting study like do do not trust
the future version of yourself treat
yourself like a little child because
well that's it like the you know another
thing on decision fatigue we know that
juries and even judges like [ __ ]
professionally trained senior people in
the legal sector industry sector yeah
will judge people as guilty more often
in the afternoons than in the mornings
just because I screams guilty fire you
know can't be asked to is that
statistically significant figure yeah
also related to blood sugar levels not
something to do with biscuit did you not
tell me was it worth had been given
biscuits are being given food or
something like that I've not seen that
what maybe maybe I've run it along from
the blood sugar thing okay there's yeah
there's also correlations with blood
sugar so yeah so basically so if you're
in court bribe the jury with biscuits
and make sure that you go morning
session biscuit
it's your sweet laughing yeah need to be
on until someone's tough you yeah stuck
in your favorite yeah so yeah the other
thing you said about cardio I love a
good morning walk as well I agree it's
not done to try and burn calories and
I'm there getting into this chasing your
tail of trying to do cardio so that you
can earn the right to eat more calories
and eat them back and all this don't get
into that cycle at all remember that the
reason you are losing fat is a hundred
percent from your calorie intake and
just leave it there so let the fat loss
be driven by your diet so the motor
essentially driven by your training okay
so you wouldn't say chief looks theory
which so to answer that the yeah sorry
can you briefly explain yourself so G
flux theory is that the effect on your
body in terms of cellular turnover and
body composition of eating a calorie
deficit of a thousand calories is
different if that deficit is created
from eating 2,000 and burning 3000
compared to eating 4,000 and burning
5,000 so there's still the net deficit
is the same at the end but actually the
body's have to go through a lot more
processing to you have to achieve the
same deficit and but it would have a
more favorable comp effect on your body
composition to do the set the latter
rather than the former that is true but
again telling someone to do that when
they want the minimum effective dose the
risk is that they end up chasing their
tail and people always underestimate the
number of calories right they
underestimate number of calories that
they eat back yeah from count from
cardio and they overestimate the number
of calories that they think that they've
burned from cardio okay
I knew a guy who gained 20 kilos in two
months I think he just got really fat
and it was because on my fitness pal he
played basketball and he was like oh
well uh I ended ninety minutes of
basketball on here and it says that it
burns 5,000 calories so I've been eating
6600 I like looking the scales look in
the mirror yeah exactly not burning the
calories and is it I don't know who ever
entered that bit into the because my
fitness powers just
user generated it's like a deer fur ah
yeah anyway sighs isn't it so it may be
something like Michael Jordan came along
with our well you know five fellas you
know okay NBA muscle basket yeah eggs
are fine so say yeah basically don't get
into that game as as Chris said walking
increasing your general NEET to your
non-exercise activity like you know
taking the stairs getting and getting
off the bus at an extra stop earlier
just general moving around not sitting
like a fat turnip during the day fine
but don't try and count the calories
that you're burning when you over in the
house and you know just see that and and
the other reason why we say lift weights
even if you are not trying to gain
muscle is that lifting weights and the
effect that it has on your body is so
much more biologically expensive than
going for a walk or a run because when
you lift weights you're tearing muscle
you're breaking down the tissue your
body then has to marshal a lot of
resources to build that back up again
which is very expensive in terms of
calories which is what you want
you also said don't fall into the trap
of toning and doing I ran a high reps 15
plus or whatever remember when you're in
a calorie deficit you're never going to
be gaining muscle anyway so if you're a
woman and you're afraid of gaining too
much muscle common fear just like I go
to the library and I'm sometimes scared
that I might get too clever so I went
for a jog once Niles I know except my
twin 100-metre godmother so I better
stop I think that's such a it's such a
good point like I leave work early as
long as I wanna make too much money yeah
like girls girls do have this fear of oh
well I'm not gonna lift too heavy
because what if I start to get arms I
don't want a cap shoulders that I don't
want like there are professional
bodybuilders female bodybuilders who
spend hours and hours and hours every
single week in the gym desperately
trying to get on the drugs as well and
and they look like they're left
and your fear is that by moving from the
8 kilo to the 10 kilo dumbbells yes it's
insulting to them actually yeah yeah
busting it is not that it is not that
easy to gain muscle trust me I've been
trying to do it for 10 years
like it's really quite hard so okay so
if we're talking about when we get to
training someone's gonna go in they're
gonna be training how many days a week
so in a in a deficit three times a week
is that is all you need because all
you're trying to do is hold on to the
muscle that you already have okay when
you are trying to gain muscle yeah you
want to be training four or five days a
week if you can't shed you are
permitting is there a potential here so
a your trace is a moment about G folks
theory aside is there a potential here
that if someone was to train if they
enjoy their training schedule and
they're able to train between sort of
three to six times a week if they're
able to up that frequency mm-hmm that
that may afford them a little bit more
on the calorie side sure if they have
the time and the freedom to do that then
why not like okay as long as you but
again if we're saying I think personally
a lot of the people that'll be listening
that have got the holiday that's coming
up I think especially for eight weeks
you can probably bring yourself now you
can put you can go balls to the wall and
go right okay like I can train for five
five days a week and I got this time
period it would be helpful because yeah
as you said you've you haven't got much
time so you may as well just do as much
girl time
so okay so what fittingly we approach
that just matter speaking here like big
picture the approach that I would prefer
is to start six months earlier but
easier time yeah and also bear in mind
that the difference you're gonna make in
the next eight weeks compared to if you
like yeah you might look a bit better
for this summer holiday but next year's
summer holiday if you carry on the
momentum
yeah you're gonna look world's better so
not for sure but yeah again we are
creatures that like to leave things
until the last minute so let's take into
account the fact that as soon as people
go away on holiday they're going to be
eating and drinking disproportionately
higher than they were yep while they
would you while they were doing this
diet to get themselves to look good and
you said yourself that you you went on a
1,500 calorie diet and then rebounded
and look
LeFleur watery for the rest of this oh
yeah you have you have one day where you
look also you have a second day way look
even better and then as soon as you have
the hangover food you just fill out and
anyone who's listening who's done a
crash diet for a holiday knows that this
is the case and you get there a holiday
near like but have to understand like I
was so lean all the way up until this
point and I've got out here and now I'm
not lean anymore well you're no longer
training you're eating an eighty percent
of your diet is coming from alcohol at a
percent of your calories come from
alcohol and carbohydrates and you
haven't had either of those for eight
weeks so again this is really
expenditures suddenly dropped it takes
suddenly gone up yeah and you're
wondering why why you don't look as good
as you did in the mirror two days ago
mm-hmm so for me I think that trying to
increase output and not drill calories
super super low if you can get your
calories closer during the prep phase to
where they're going to be when you're
away you're going to be less sensitive
can you explain about why why having low
calories in the bill that will make you
more sensitive to them once you get out
there so I mean I made this mistake
myself on the meditation retreat for
example as well where I've lost loads of
weight from being in hospital actually
wasn't dieting per se but and then
suddenly went for it and obviously when
you're in hospital on your ill your
expenditures quite high because you
there's there's so much immunity stuff
taking hold on a lot of energy right and
and so then I went from that to having
recovered and sit for 12 for 10 days in
silence with unlimited vegetarian food
so low protein food no activity no
training and I did regain a lot of fat
but yeah it's it's simply that there is
an abundance of food and alcohol as you
said alcohol will stimulate your
appetite further you can create a
reactive hypoglycemia which will make
you hungry and get the munchies
afterwards plus the general lack of
restraint that you or the inhibition
yeah the the disinhibition that you get
from drinking so all of that will
contribute just to overeating plus
it's fizzy whether you're in the Sun
yeah physiologically as well I'm gonna
guess the in metabolism will have
dropped during the practice
yeah because intake of food is going
down and intakes come down and you've
lost weight so your actually your
maintenance calories have dropped even
if there's no metabolic damage per se
you don't still you you and then that
means that when you get out there that
the the danger is overshooting
yeah yeah definitely and it's very
difficult I think another thing as well
to consider is one of the most fun
things about going on holiday is the
planning and the anticipation for it as
you build up to it now that anticipation
you can use the anticipatory energy to
motivate you to go and train and that's
good that's a good use of that energy
but one thing that you don't want to do
is absolutely hate your life for 810
weeks in the build-up to this holiday I
think people need to appreciate that if
you are if you're below 13 percent body
fat 13 to 12 some body faster you're
approaching outline of your abs yeah
I'll go interrupts with some visible
vascularity maybe in bicep and forearm
like to 90% of the people on the beach
you're gonna look awesome like you look
like you lift and you're probably
shredded to even like a slightly lower
proportion of those piece so yeah Johnny
mentioned this and I've definitely
experiment show you have as well we're
like we if you've been training for some
time and you're you're like trying to
diet from yeah 13 to 11 or from 9% to 7%
you know I've got to make these fine
chains or actually I've lost a bit of
seismic Delta actually like these
differences utter only to you yeah no
wonder or is anyone else concerned on
the beach you're either a you're either
a Bobby Bill burr or you're not only
Dobler and so like part yeah like and
people are easily someone who doesn't
train like the untrained eye will look
at a guy who's 65 kilos and has ABS yeah
he's huge yeah because the illusion is
there that's it yeah
getting hung up on the small details
compared to if you were just generally
in shape even if it's a few percentage
points out of your own reference point
yeah it's such a big source of
insecurity yeah and I think as well like
you especially if you've been lifting
for a little while a lot of friends who
I know that you know the Train
consistently but maybe they're not super
strict with their looking sure the
minute don't worry like we'll make it
like it really really do you shouldn't
be obsessing over it like if you're
walking around at 10%
allow yourself do you know what it is
here's something to think about
we're talking about this rebound effect
of cinching out there and you start
having beer and all the rest of him I
bet that a significant proportion of
people who are cited about 10% body fat
let's say which is probably fairly
maintainable for people who train
consistently if they went into a holiday
on maintenance calories or just a little
bit above with a slightly increased
training output that after day three or
four they would look better than the
same person that they were had they
drilled themselves into the ground with
the deficit and then got this rebound
effect so when you said that day two and
three of the holiday you looked your
best and then got worse is simply that
yeah you've carved up almost yeah and
then but then you keep carving up more
than yes yeah and you need to just
wholly unprepared to deal with it so
this solution that I would propose to
today is this the simplest way as well
meaning that you finished your diet you
aggressive approach that you had to take
because you're an idiot you've left it
until the last minute rather than trying
to track your calories while you're away
and stressing out over it pick the the
shittest most pointless meal of the day
usually breakfast especially if you're
in there beat there and you're in a hurt
on you getting boiled eggs and like what
cross arms and things never been move
either it's not it's not boiled eggs
across on either case what we're gonna
be for breakfast still it's probably
okay I mean that's excellent weather
thermogenic oh yeah so far talking about
caffeine so stay on the well I'm not
going to endorse having pills for
breakfast but yeah like pick the meal
which is the most pointless doesn't
provide a social purpose
really help with you hunger most people
find that they just eat breakfast
because they feel like they have to or
they [ __ ] what about hangover okay if if
breakfast serves you Hanover great but I
mean what I'm saying is like yeah pick
the meal that doesn't doesn't really
contribute to your day in that sense
like I know a lot of people they're like
all the people always told me breakfast
most important meal of the day so anyway
even though I'm never hungry in the
morning it's like well don't eat it like
save it yeah so do that and then
instantly you freed up an extra 4 or 500
calories or more yeah that you can
dedicate to drinking to an evening meal
whatever you want yeah or restrict your
eating window that's another way of
doing it so to stop thinking the day
being means being Frank I think some of
this is gonna be difficult to do when
you're when you're away if you've got a
five-day this is no easier than tracking
your calories in Toronto oh yeah I think
I just think that when you enroll though
like things go you know power is a the
ebb is so low like you so in that case
if if it's not an option to change how
you're eating while you're on holiday
then you need to prep over a longer
period yeah it's one of the other rate
and I think the the wait wait wait
rebound is related to slightly to the
speed of weight loss but more so to the
amount of weight lost hmm and the way
that you can counteract that is every
time you've lost a bit of weight hold
out there for a while
establish a new set point yeah and then
do a step wise diet and people that do
that hold on to their weight loss more
than people who just drop and then don't
correct diet over and that's just
rebound so we're talking about not
trying to go super super low on the
calories before we go away on holiday
because what that's going to end up
doing is creating this environment for
rebound effect which ruins the hard-won
leanness but you've just sacrificed
eight weeks or 10 weeks for or whatever
it might be you're saying focus on
muscular movements focus on resistance
training rather than relying on cardio
if someone who does want to add cardio
in how do they do it
so but as long as we make those three
days that you're lifting weights sacred
hmm so and then up into four if you want
to this is assuming that you've got more
space in your shed you'll to do five or
six training sessions a week and fine
you've got the resistance training
covered once you're training three or
four times a week there's very limited
benefit especially in a deficit to
adding in an extra few days of lifting
weights because you haven't got the fuel
available to build the muscle and so you
may as well use your fifth and your
sixth training day in a week to do some
cardio
okay in which case I would suggest do
the cardio that you enjoy the most
so because then you're more likely to
stick to it so if you hate rowing but
you're told that rowing is the best
waste burn calories and you're gonna
stick to it for a couple of weeks and
fall off the wagon yeah if you like hill
sprints I mean if you're not that fine
do them if you know CrossFit is and I've
come full circle so I've come 180 on
this yeah because I really like having
seen the results of tell on you but
could so it cross fit really in a lot of
ways it's it's giving you the community
environment mmm the motivation to push
yourself more than you would there's a
lot of volume that you're accumulating
just from the amount of lifting in there
yeah and it's very it's very high cardio
demand as well so it takes all of those
boxes so so really as far as that goes
just to cross for three weeks
well you could do yeah I mean if you if
you're not used to training but idea
going balls I mean well I think what
we've done so one of the problems that
you have with doing it and doing
CrossFit for something like this is that
technically it's very demanding their
barriers to entry for a lot of the
movements are actually quite high so
this is it you're not gonna be able to
hit the ground running not in terms of
intensity because you're not even gonna
have learned all of the movements yeah I
think maybe something like a boot camp
might give you a little bit of external
accountability yeah if your own trainer
there that's able to adjust your
technique and me doing cardio on your
own is it's pretty miserable especially
if you want to push yourself quite hard
but you know you can find almost
everywhere
you can find it good bootcamp class for
a tenner a session and if you paying 10
pounds once a week or twice a week you
know for if that's what it takes to get
you to get that cardio in then cool yeah
and they you know boot camp runners the
boot camp organizers want you to come
back so they're gonna make it as fun as
they can make it yeah they'll have
partner exercises and all that stuff so
yeah you get you get you get kidded into
thinking that it's fun but it's by the
end of the session you actually look at
what you've done to yourself if you
think [ __ ] this really hurt and that's a
big advantage and it's the same
advantage for CrossFit there was no way
that I would've owned like when I came
to CrossFit once or a couple of times
anyway it was great but there's no way
that I would put myself through that on
my own yeah but it's because if if you
when you're with a group and if you just
start at me like I'm leaving they saw
they had so would you would you say that
potentially during the prep to go away
on holiday gave me another one of the
guys who's also going away to be a
training partner would be odd and
absolutely yeah
ok as long as you as long as you don't
mind that you're both look better if you
just want to look better than you make
this is the Highlander thing like that
can only be one yeah it's as if you
think it's a zero-sum game of like
you've got the group of people that
you're going with and there's only a
certain amount of to sabotage them with
like cake leave cake on their desk is
which is fine to buy a load of cake so
basically 50 quid either spend on
bootcamp for you mate or spend on cake
for you mates yeah depending on how much
you value and you are and then
relatively I haven't lost any weight but
everyone else in my friend friend circle
has gained [ __ ] know that she's the
same a jet bloody help right so actually
slack psycho everything we've said so
far get all of you mates to gain 6.4
kilos over the eight weeks which is
probably a lot easier get gain one
percent of the body weight per yeah
we're fine engine yeah even though we've
we've we've come to us we've come to a
solution there okay so plan yourself
training partner probably one preferably
one who you're going away with but yes
it means that you're both working
towards the same schedule you're looking
at resistance training three to four
times a week yep if you want to add some
more training in then another want
two sessions of enjoyable cardio of
cardio and whatever it is we're talking
between 30 minutes to an hour yeah if
you can spare it yeah I think I do think
that a lot of people I think you also
get Julie's wouldn't represent it if we
busy unreasonably tight yeah yeah and
that's one of the reasons that I don't
do cardio because one I'm lazy to my
schedule is so tight and I have to go
for the highest yield that lowest
hanging fruit first
but yeah the the other thing outside of
cardio is the non-exercise activity that
we talked about so I'm terrible with
this yeah make me too you know if you
work at a desk a lot then try and push
the daily activities just fit it into
it's not formal cardio it's walking to
the shop walking to work have a walking
or that energy something like that
exactly anything that involves movement
but isn't formalized like you don't have
to put on your shorts and go and do
something for all of this will help to
not let the your metabolism drop too far
through the floor as well yeah which
will also mitigate this rebound effect
once we go out there so okay so we've
got the three to four sessions in terms
of muscular training for that push-pull
legs something similar yeah so the
simplest way I like this was from
Spencer Nadal ski who he's a family
physician and talks to you this is the
kind of standard exercise advice he
gives to patients which i think is great
because he can't get it wrong he's go to
the gym three times a week do some kind
of pushing some kind of pulling and some
kind of legs in each session for obvious
we'll do that in every session well that
I mean not yet or as you said you can do
a push session and push session and a
leg session oh yeah that's a push push
push push
yeah push pull legs on each of the days
okay I think for some people that may be
a more easy to to workout split so have
the listeners have you going to
resources on protein fitness comm that
the guys can have a little bit of a look
at yeah we have so who if you go to
protein fitness comm and search for the
propane protocol infographic there is a
full training program laid out for you
it's four days a week it covers all of
the bases
it's
structured in a way that you will avoid
injury and maintain structural balance
and it's all laid out in there and
there's a diet framework in there as
well so it's just on a big it's a big
long image right it's yeah big not
animated it's like a big illustration
full yeah full infographic site you
scroll for a little while but
everything's in there exactly everything
that the the only thing I would change
about that is because we're talking
about a short time frame you're gonna be
need to be more aggressive with the
calories and if you want to really take
things up a notch and guarantee that you
will lose so we have a we have a program
called the 28-day shred which typically
people lose 5% of their body weight
within 24 28 days Wow
so that is done and it's relatively easy
as far as losing 5% it's the easiest way
that we know off together that much
anyway so yes yes Isis push the red
panic button
yes stations right this is four weeks
till I go away I need to do it and how
much is up that's 67 pounds okay and
you'll get lifetime access to that you
get support weekly weekly calls to
one-on-one calls with you with your
coach and it's basically everything that
you need just that's cool you know done
for yourself basically if people want to
step it up a notch then they've got that
as a as a resource if they want the free
resource then they've got propane
fitness calm and search for the propane
protocol and if they are too headstrong
or lazy or anything else to not want to
do either of those things then we've got
it laid out for them here train
resistance training three to four times
a week couple of sessions of cardio make
sure that you get someone who you can
train with get some external
accountability in terms of diet
typically for the typical size man so
511 80 kilos you need to be looking at
what about 2002 sort of 1800 calories
something like that yeah I mean started
start at 2000 take your daily body
weight every morning post poo
pre-breakfast
naked at the same time yeah wait I'll
put a link I'll put a link to the set of
Sandler
that I've got which were six pounds
great and the perfectly accurate and use
MyFitnessPal to track your weight so
MyFitnessPal is also free create an
account download the app on your phone
put your weight in every single day and
it will track it over time it will make
sure it's important to get every day and
yeah if using the some of the digital
scales then that's gonna give you a more
accurate reading yeah take that daily
body weight every morning over the week
calculate the average so if you my
Fitness Pal might do this all those it
does a week on week fine our propane
spreadsheets will do this as well or if
use a why things or Withings yeah Wi-Fi
scale yeah that will that super felt
like it's linked with Johnny Johnny I
don't go to choosing unit sponsor foods
here it goes to the grid and then like
some guy comes out with an envelope and
they cut you watermelon for you and it's
amazing but no I think um yeah once
you've got that then you can start to
see whether the two thousand calories is
producing the expected if someone's
doesn't know if someone doesn't know
what 2,000 calories is how can they
roughly eat 2,000 calories a day as
we're talking man 80 kilos 2,000
calories female maybe 1600 typically
between fifty and sixty kilos something
like that yeah maybe go slightly lower
if you've got a short timeframe maybe
fifteen or fourteen hundred okay but it
has the thing is the starting point is
just a starting point to see how your
weights responding and yeah because you
may you might stay in that first week
you might drop two kilos oh yeah in
which case your calories are too low
yeah or if you don't if your weight
doesn't change and the calories are too
high so the adjustments have to be made
week on weekend that's where the magic
happens really so and again try and keep
your average weight change between not
0.5 and 1 percent of your body weight if
it goes too far above that you start to
step into
cutting into your recovery too much and
drop in testosterone and increase in
cortisol yeah depression symptoms Alaska
I think another one who the things that
we need to mention we ever mentioned so
far is it like there are other costs
that other things going on in your life
outside of how good you're going to look
for your holiday that's alluded to this
earlier on like you don't want to
absolutely bin your life just to look a
little bit leaner while you go away
especially seen as presumably this
summer holidays something that you're
supposed to be looking forward to yeah I
don't want you don't want to go another
period miserable yeah you've got you
know just why I'm saying start as early
as possible you know or like at least
yeah fine follow the advice in this
podcast get ready for the next eight
weeks or as much as you can but keep up
the momentum and focus on that I mean
it's definitely definitely as well like
a lot of people lean out for eight weeks
go away maybe have a little bit of this
rebound that we've discussed here but
within seven days of coming back you
could get back to the set point that you
were at before hunt quite easily exactly
don't think holidays over back to the
year I've ruined it I've ruined it I'm
never going to be leaning against a well
no that's the exact opposite so a
structured and consistent training
program is sort of number one that's the
zennith so what you and I have done is a
proper proper diet get lean once and for
all
I got lost how I dieted was 2013 hi it's
been five or six months getting bone
shredded like pancreas leaks giving big
skin lean and then gradually reversed
reverse dieting which is systematically
increasing the calories up to a point
where body weight isn't it isn't
influenced by it yeah and then if it
starts to spill over then you pull
calories back painstaking process but
what it's meant is that I've now topped
out my calories mmm it supports your
training eating as much food as you as
you want really you're very happy with
the amount of food that you're eating
maintaining your post diet condition and
I'm still reaping the benefits of that
five years later yeah yes perhaps you're
still absolutely still add lean thanks
to that diet so yeah the short you don't
need to get lean wants exactly get lean
once properly do it
gradually and then systematically
reverse back okay and then shall set
yourself for five years or so surfing
area so someone's someone's gone away
they've managed to hold on to the
training protocol they've kept
controlled with their diet
up until then if you've only got eight
weeks are you allowing someone have a
refeed day or are they just on this and
they're just in the Deaf's air but yeah
you can do a refeed day oh and so you
can have one day where you would maybe
bump up your calories to to the half
thousand to three hours and cars and I
think I'm glad you said that because
reefy can mean can be quite flexible
meaning and so yeah you can undo all of
the deficit for an entire week in one
day being 10,000 calories ah yeah easily
so sonís and when you're dieted eating
10,000 calories is not beyond the
facility when we're talking about doing
a refeed day one day week or I would be
more tempted to say one day every
fortnight especially given that you've
got this short timeframe mm-hmm
what calories are just 30% higher for
example it's not it's not like an
absolutely no apex but I think it's
important I know that it's important for
me to work towards a day where I have a
little bit more leniency I can feel it a
bit more satiated also choose to do your
refeed day on a day where you're
training a muscle part that you really
want to go for it on if you are used to
eating at training in a deficit where
your training quality maybe isn't quite
where you're used to it or where you'd
want it to be if you have this day where
you've eaten a little bit more your
training outputs gonna be so much better
you're gonna go in pumps gonna be more
improved your level of strengths going
more improved energy levels feeling of
society like yeah absolutely
everything's gonna be fueled by that
research feeling of society that feeling
Society feeling of satiety so final
thing so want to go away on holiday and
they've come back mm-hmm how do they
then slowly recom practice read ayat
that you've said so that they can
maximize the return on all the
sacrifices they're made in a couple of
months leading up to this
there's some ones come back from holiday
yeah they've gone away is it maybe done
the thing if they gained any weight yeah
we're away I think it's I think
it's very very imprudent to achieve it
that's gonna happen so rather than get
into the self flagellation
self-punishment cycle straight away come
home restore your momentum with training
yeah I think I've got some training
again that's number one
yeah just eat normally for a while don't
don't try and go into a big crazy cycle
do that for a couple of weeks set
yourself a baseline then decide has the
weight has the excess weight come off it
may have come off naturally just having
returned from you know even flying
traveling somewhere will increase your
weight and it might be what is it
probably cuz it disrupts your your blood
salt sand and water retention and that
kinda things are significant
yeah is really at least with our clients
like it I mean it's it's not a huge
proportion well it's also that I mean
it'll affect your scale weight but it
won't employ it doesn't mean that you've
got fatter it just yeah it's just the
list it disrupts the data that you're
seeing on there okay that's in terms of
shoes yeah so wait till you've
established a new baseline and then you
can say look actually I'm lean enough I
could go back and do with gaining some
muscle so I'm gonna spend the next year
gaining muscle and the mother time for
my next holiday I can do five or six
weeks before before the holiday yeah and
just cut a bit of fat I think I think
definitely for me getting back into
training as fast as possible is a really
big deal a few things to remember is
that if you've just been wearing a party
holiday and you've filled yourself with
all kinds of substances that first
training session it's it's gonna be
pretty uncomfortable
you've sweats gonna be viscous and
multicolored and you're gonna be really
it's gonna be not an enjoyable
experience so however I heard about hey
I don't know whether this is true but
someone said that LSD is stored in your
fat cells and so there were all of these
people who lost weight being in a part
of the summer of love in the 60s and
then lost weight during a mid-life diet
sort of maybe in the 90s and we're
driving on the road and the adipose
cells would have released so it's a lot
of psychedelics back into the
bloodstream and there were people
tripping while they were driving oh man
I mean I'm not sure that the same is
probably true I'm
should the same is true for speed
masquerading as cocaine insanity but
yeah this is definitely you're gonna
come back you're gonna feel like [ __ ]
your training is not going to be
tremendously good but you will feel
better if you can get yourself back into
that routine so another benefit to
getting a baseline I suppose if you had
a bunch of substances just a couple of
weeks where you're just yeah don't don't
obsess it is noisy and yeah okay
get you sleep gain sleep back it's not
taking drugs stop drinking all the time
and get back into some training and
enjoy it make yourself feel a little bit
more healthy remember that and it's try
and fall back in love with training cuz
it the thing the thing that's so
impressive to everybody about someone
who is lean the understands what it
takes to get lean is that they
appreciate the sacrifice that person's
made to get there because it is a
miserable process to not eat as much
food as your body wants and to then try
and get your body to exert physical
prior exercises on top of that like it's
it just sucks hmm so allow yourself to
fall back in love with your training if
you've always liked walking rowing
running hill sprints jogging CrossFit
martial arts whatever it is do the
training that is going to allow you to
remain physically active as easily as
possible and then make sure that you
keep on top of you
resistance training make sure that
you're not letting your weights drop too
much keep tracking your weight when you
get home and then yeah take it from
there
yeah you've probably covered most of the
bits there solid advice I think that's
that's the that's the complete picture
so to be honest everything that
discussed in this podcast if you just do
this now until that your holiday in
eight weeks time I think it you're gonna
make the most progress that you can in
that time I think you'd be laughing so
let's break it down again going from the
top find your training partner some what
are you going away with yeah or if you
can't find one account dependency
partner some there's an up I think way
you can you put 500 pounds into or a
thousand pounds or whatever into what
like an escrow account escrow yeah that
gets released if you don't do the thing
you said you're going to do that's yeah
that's one way to motivate you say but
try and find a training we like we have
a client that gave a thousand pounds to
his mom and was like mom if I drink
before Friday then oh my god you got a
thousand pounds imagine if your mom just
wouldn't spend a thousand pounds ah yeah
or if your mom just kept leaving shots
around training three or four times a
week resistance a couple of times of of
cardio maybe on a morning try and get a
10 to 15 20 minute walking fasted like
coffee before you go I also like what
you said about just get training done in
the morning and then just like that's
the win for the day yeah you know that
you take it off the list and you don't
need to worry but you're also more
likely to stick to your diet because
then you you've not had a stumbly [ __ ]
day where like you know I haven't been
to the gym and dyers come out the window
whatever but whereas if you've started
it as you mean to go on yeah get some
get some easy wins and do you bail and
if the sessions one of them then so be
it
um push for legs we think for a for a
session yeah a split you can get a good
breakdown with that problem Fitness calm
have a look at the problem protocol diet
you're going to be looking at around
about 2,000 calories a day for men and
about 16 15 1600 for women to start with
you to begin with an interest based on
how you weights moving yep tracking your
weight in the morning after you have
been for we and poo but before you've
had food naked yep
set scales will be linked in the show
notes which you can get there like five
or six pounds and they'll do you for the
rest of time as well
My Fitness Pal use that to track your
weight and see how your weights getting
on throughout the day don't get caught
up with too much meal timing BCAAs
before and after training Mac all of
that stuff yeah you your only goal
during the next eight weeks is hit your
average weekly calorie intake and your
minimum training volume like don't don't
get hung up on that don't buy any
supplements don't yeah any of that is
distraction the observation so grass-fed
predigested MCT oil in your coffee
before you train and throw them up here
and you know all of these only if it's
the one that costs $100 for the little
turbine is grass-fed and broken and the
other case it's gonna make a big
difference
and then when you get out there maybe
don't go completely crazy on the
baguettes if you've got the option of
having vodka Diet Coke on a night or if
you're drinking during the so that was
another thing I was going to mention
actually yeah I forgot about this which
was when you were going out drinking
consider what is your intention is your
intention I really like the taste of
beer so I'm gonna drink lots of beers or
is it I want to get as drunk as I can
without gaining fat if that's the case
then treat alcohol like any other drug
like you want to have the highest
concentration and to get as drunk as
possible for the least amount of money
and least amount of calories this is
searched you sir
like approach I've heard you I've heard
you made these make this argument so 20
times so ten beers is gonna let's say
beer is two to three hundred calories
then you've instantly after your whole
day is color and color completely [ __ ]
it so whereas if you say right I'm not
gonna eat 3-4 hours before I start
drinking to sensitize myself to being
drunk as much as possible now I'm gonna
have spirits for some you know some high
density form of alcohol most Muslim a
program to try to get drift
front-loaded so drink so much early as
possible in the night so that you then
by the time you end up going home it's
starting to wear off you sleep better
you haven't blown your calories too much
you've got the most of the alcohol for
the least amount of effort calories and
time I think if anyone implements this
by the holiday anyone goes right nuts
little people to do anyway you know as
much as possible you know that evening
meal right well I'm just gonna have meat
vodka another meatwad car over here
please slowly and you wouldn't just have
one you'd be like I'll have ten just lay
right now I'll put immediately
you're not just fashionable so you know
that maximum recoverable volume yeah is
this like maximum consumable alcohol
yeah exact without throwing up hit below
maximum are you doing a throat because
then you've wasted the money wasted on
what do you know exactly yeah although
you may have got rid of some more
calories thing is I know people that
naturally drink like that but if that's
more just like a it's kind of a novelty
thing is now oh look at the egg bombs
art is just like yeah yeah so okay so
we've got that when you come back start
back into training try and find
something that you like and begin
tracking your weight again and plan for
summer 2019 now yeah as opposed to eight
weeks so and be naughty don't be naughty
right K by then
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
you